we're thinking about how jokes travel
okay we're very international audience
as we know we've got Alan Union okay
we've asked our non British friends if
they will share a favorite joke with us
okay so first off is Emmy is it Emmy
Emmy
there's Emmy hello let's do stand up
stand up Emmy
hi so were you from France another
French person okay so if you do your
joke in French sort of line by line
Julia could you translate a joke
if you don't like the joke and then
we'll see if we find it funny no
pressure in me for a friendly crowd okay
off you go off first line of your joke
don't similar songs Keo Hondo's not bad
he's old
yeah it's a monkey who enters into a bar
wani again okay so monkey goes into a
bar eternal Doberman and he is asking
the the barman a scuba divin and do you
have bananas I knew that were you that
not that bad better no we don't have any
banner resourceful to you if it was
everyday banana yeah he didn't did the
monkey continues to say do you have
banana no NEPAD Bandar no we don't have
anybody's cuckoos available man come on
do you have banana ok lysee Navy
equities if you change em demo day CGI
banana j vu cruel allankapoor premio oh
listen kick you see keep saying daddy
about you you're asking for banana I
hammer your tongue on the wall for fun i
hammer a nail
Oh Julie I found it very funny
french toast or ease because oh he's not
before it ends but so it's okay so it's
a little is good with a vide crew the
the monkey ass do you have nails no no
is you've literally banana
do you have an ass
Hey
okay one more
lady from Columbia where's the lady for
Columbia oh there you are hello stand up
- hi what's your name
Patricia Oh Patricia Oh Patricia
Patricia okay so what should we hearing
what would let me use excuse me well who
can translate that
what is it quick is it quick I could
make it quick well tell it quickly in
Spanish and I want Ellen okay anything
but English all right just Halliday oh
you're ruined
every key ruined it tell him Spanish Vic
Toews amigos encuentra despues de mucho
tiempo de no verse a y MP sir Mar del
pasado de los amigos etc Mesa no TRO add
visto a Al Queda possibly say no a be a
Maria a Maria quiénes Maria no Maria
Maria una chica muy muy Delgada pl'anna
no tenia Teta seen acuerdo puede la vela
semana pasada que esta la cirugía
cosmetic alas Teta no
Oh
I think I've got the gist of it but I
don't know if I'm gonna do it justice
a monkey with huge boobs okay tell is it
okay to our friends meet after a long
time they old school friends and they
talk about the past and have you seen
these how do you see someone he said oh
yes I saw Maria funnily enough I saw
Maria last week who is Maria you
remember Maria she was some very slim
very flat-chested you remember not very
pretty
oh yes I remember her yes well I saw her
and she is looking live is ah why she
had pleasure you know breast enlargement
no she's got thirty-one arthritis
is that huge best noises got terrible
arthritis
electrons like English
that's not night that's mr. Corbitt talk
with Allah otaku so I go to read but as
I'm reading I'm loud show me the money
know what I mean that's all I'm saying
brother show me the money